Träge döst die Schafherde
im Schatten der Bäume.
Die ersten Lämmer des Jahres sind da.
Deshalb hält Schäfer Florian Preis die 240
Tiere zurzeit hier zwischen Lagerhallen
und Fabrikgebäuden bei Oberhausen
im Westen Deutschlands.
Sonst ist er mit der Herde auf Wanderschaft
auf den Grünflächen der Industrieregion.
Preis ist einer der wenigen Schäfer,
die es überhaupt noch in Deutschland gibt.
Es gibt noch tausend Berufsschäfer
in Deutschland, [das] ist nicht die Menge.
Ich kenn wenig junge Leute,
die es noch machen wollen.
Ich mach es mit Leidenschaft weiterhin.
Ich mach’s auch so lang,
bis ich den hier machen muss.
Und [es] ist mit Sicherheit
’n aussterbender Beruf.
Also, hat keiner Bock drauf.
Man verdient halt nicht viel dabei,
man wird halt nicht reich dabei.
Die Schafe bringen ihm Geld
durch den Verkauf des Fleisches,
und weil sie gegen Geld
öffentliche Grünflächen abweiden.
Früher war auch die
Wolle ein gutes Geschäft.
Heute deckt der Verkauf nicht mal
die Kosten für das Scheren der Schafe.
Schöne Merino-Landschafwolle.
Ich mit meinen Merino-Landschafen, da die
qualitativ schon eine der besten …
die beste Wolle haben,
krieg ich noch über ’n Euro pro Kilo.
Und Kollegen von mir,
die andere Rassen haben,
die kriegen halt noch deutlich
weniger an Geld pro Kilo.
Das ist [sind] dann 45 bis 65 Cent pro Kilo.
Die verkaufen die schon
teilweise gar nicht mehr,
sondern die verbrennen die
oder schmeißen die direkt auf die Deponie.
Preis’ Wolle geht nach China,
dort wird sie weiterverarbeitet
und landet in Bettwaren,
Polsterungen, Teppichen
oder in der Textilindustrie.
Produkte, die zum Teil wieder
auf den europäischen Markt gehen
und dort teuer verkauft werden.
Schneiderin Brigitte Pappe
bringt das in Rage.
Es ist total absurd, wenn man überlegt, die
Aufkäufer hier kaufen die Wolle auf,
schicken die nach China zum Waschen,
und dann wird sie wieder zurückgeschickt,
nach Paris,dann ist da ein Faden drum,
und dann ist sie auf einmal toll.
Brigitte Pappe hat sich das
Schneidern selbst beigebracht.
Eigentlich ist sie gelernte Zahnarzthelferin.
Doch jetzt ist sie Unternehmerin
mit einer Leidenschaft für Wolle.
Ihr neuestes Projekt:
Mosel-Tweed.
Da ich ein Fan von Harris-Tweed bin,
was ja auch aus Wolle ist,
hab ich mich damit mal auseinandergesetzt,
ob unsere Schafe hier in dieser Region,
ob diese Wolle geeignet ist für ein Tuch.
Und sie ist sehr gut geeignet für ein Tuch.
Und das war dann so der Grund,
wo ich gesagt hab, okay,
dann kümmer ich mich jetzt
mal um das Retten der Wolle.
Den Stoff lässt sie in Deutschland herstellen,
ausschließlich mit Wolle aus ihrer Region.
100 Meter hat sie schon.
Mit ihren Mitarbeitern näht sie daraus
Westen, Mützen und Sakkos.
So muss das sein, schau mal.
Unterstützung bekommt Pappe
von der Wagenfelder Spinnerei.
Den Stoff in einem globalisierten Textilmarkt
regional herzustellen, ist schwierig.
Zu hoch sind die Produktionskosten,
zu gering die Mengen.
Auch Pappes Wolle wird hier verarbeitet,
gefärbt und zu einem Faden gesponnen.
Deutsche Wolle spielt im internationalen
Massenmarkt jedoch keine Rolle.
Wir bekommen unsere Wolle
aus der ganzen Welt.
Wir bekommen sie von Neuseeland,
von Australien, von Südamerika.
Wir bekommen sie auch aus England.
Wir beziehen unsere Wolle, je nachdem,
welche Ansprüche wir erfüllen müssen,
bekommen wir unsere Wollen von überallher.
Auf 220 Tonnen
neuseeländischer Wolle pro Monat
kommen hier 10 Tonnen
deutsche Wolle – pro Jahr.
Der Rohstoff aus Down Under als
Massenprodukt ist reiner, etwas weicher,
effizienter produziert
und deshalb sogar billiger.
Weber unterstützt das Projekt,
glaubt in naher Zukunft aber nicht an
das Big Business mit deutscher Wolle.
Der Verbraucher ist heute leider
nicht bereit, mehr Geld zu investieren,
mehr Geld auf den Ladentisch zu legen.
Für ihn ist die Schnelllebigkeit wichtig.
Die Mode, der Modewechsel.
Und dafür muss es möglichst billig sein.
Hier muss ’n Umdenken stattfinden.
Das wäre wünschenswert.
Brigitte Pappe glaubt trotzdem an ihren Stoff.
Auch wenn sie oft noch teuer ist,
die Nachfrage nach
nachhaltiger Kleidung wächst.
Pappes Ziel ist es, irgendwann 10.000 Meter
Mosel-Tweed in Auftrag zu geben.
Einen Massenmarkt
will sie damit aber nicht bedienen.
Also, mein erstes Ziel ist es,
Nachmacher zu finden.
Ich will keine Millionen.
Ich möchte zufriedene Mitarbeiter.
Ich möchte am Ende des Monats wissen,
dass ich ein Einkommen hab
für mein Auskommen.
Und ich möchte mit allen,
die an dieser Kette zusammenhängen,
also mit mir zusammenarbeiten,
gerne mit mir zusammenarbeiten,
weil sie einen Preis bekommen,
der ihrer Arbeit wert ist.